et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis londres avec martin mc cauley il
est analyste politique c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
martin mc cauley merci est d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors ces
mesures dites présenté par boris johnson
comment elles ont été reçues par la
population outre-manche plutôt avec
hostilité à une pluie on voyait une
photographie de bourges qui dit tout ce
qu'il ya à dire sur sur le visuel est
épuisée après sept mois de prison
expriment la nécessité qu'on m'explique
comment résoudre ce problème qui semble
tout à fait insoluble louis jeune âge il
a annoncé de nouvelles restrictions
le gouvernement a publié une application
car je vais télécharger que je suis à
londres l'oscar une zone où le niveau
d'alerté est moyen
c'est le niveau le plus bas c'est à dire
que les restaurants et les pubs doivent
fermer à 22h mais que nul ne peut pas se
rassembler à plus de six personnes dans
you enjoy
cela continuera jusqu'à ce que
l'association pire
la difficulté pour les scientifiques il
n'apas étudié les mathématiques la
physique la chimie ne connais pas ces
sciences dures qui enseigne la
probabilité et des statistiques qui a
vécu que toute connaissance est
temporaire et il se fonde sur des avis
reçus de scientifiques par exemple en
mars et en avril qui se sont avérés ne
pas d'être correct il est donc dans une
situation très difficile car les sens
ils ne sont pas d'accord sur ce qu'il
faut faire et il doit décider à qui il
faut pas faire confiance aux banques à
certains scientifiques veulent
confinement total serres castet maire a
demandé à un coût film en dur pour deux
à trois semaines
mais le premier ministre est contre
cette idée car cela paralyserait
l'économie et c'est là le grand problème
propre aux régions de ce qu'il doit
trouver un équilibre h à12 entre les
conseils des scientifiques
l'homme qui demande du venin confinement
qui a dit qu on signerait draconiennes à
ceux qui gèrent les travailleurs par
exemple qui veulent continuer à
travailler car par exemple le secteur de
la restauration devrait fermer s'il y
avait en fine moins dures telles que les
scientifiques le conseil de vol de vélo
qui donc c'est une situation très
complexe pour le premier ministre
et cette fois ci ils essayent de jauge
le cloud oublier que les restrictions à
bonnières iphone auront l'effet désiré
use deux le nombre des de contamination
hier était de 14 et c'était le plus
attendu depuis quelques temps et la
crainte que cela continue à augmenter et
si c'est le cas alors la situation
pourrait devenir critique vous savez au
landeron pas mieux loti est une région
où l'alerté de niveau moyen
la situation est encore acceptable la
ville de liverpool par exemple est
confiné avec un niveau d alerte est très
élevé et d'autres régions du nord-ouest
de l'angleterre également de niveau
d'alerté élevé une invention et la
population et ciblée car les chiens
certains scientifiques disent quelque
chose et d'autres le contre elle chaque
fois que je sors je porte un masque
humain car on m'a dit de le faire
le fonds d'al car certains scientifiques
disent qu'on n'a pas besoin de masques
cela ne fait pas le look une
différenciation est censé confusion la
fille du premier ministre en tout cas
est très compliqué et il doit essayer de
trouver un kart
ces deux extrêmes entre les
scientifiques et ceux qui veulent une
économie ce normal en quelques mois ce
que le ton de boris johnson a changé est
ce que vous le sentez moins optimiste
aujourd'hui
et puis le côté c'est la première fois
toujours été optimiste quant à ses
robots seul mais moi je plume coule
mieux cet argent qui passait à portée de
la dire ce que la population il faut
qu'il soit heureux de tous était un
dirigeant peut être populaire il ne veut
pas il dira des choses négatives à la
population il est donc très attentifs à
ce qu'il veut propager un message
positif et beaucoup de personnes ne le
crois pas car ils voient ce qui se passe
en empêcher a admis que certaines
personnes avaient seulement considèrent
qu'il veut revenir un dictateur qui le
met comme joe enrayer la démocratie car
par exemple il refuse le débat
parlementaire le bouton il n'aime pas
cela pour eux c'est un risque pour la
démocratie et pour la liberté
donc il souhaiterait prendre leurs
propres décisions oui toutes les
personnes en angleterre
je voudrais choisir eux mêmes mais la
majorité des gens voudraient que le
gouvernement soit plus sévère qu'il le
mette en place des mesures à plus forte
pour mettre un terme à cette mesure
donc que des mesures fortes sont des
meilleurs des yeux le visage te corrige
personne ne montre bien qu'il était
épuisé et je trouverais très difficile
de trouver des solutions
en tout cas ils implorent le public de
suivre ses directives car cela aidera la
population
un grand merci martin mc cauley d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes analyste politique